you mentioned humanoid robot so what do
you think about Optimus about Tesla bot
do you think we'll have robots in the
factory in in the home in 10 20 30 40 50
years yeah I think it's a very hard
project I think it's going to take a
while but who else is going to build
humano robots at scale yeah and I think
it is a very good form factor to go
after because like I mentioned the the
world is designed for human reform
Factor these things would be able to
operate our machines they would be able
to sit down in chairs uh potentially
even drive cars uh basically the world
is designed for humans that's the form
factor you want to invest into and make
work over time uh I think you know
there's another school of thought which
is okay pick a problem and design a
robot to it but actually designing a
robot and getting a whole data engine
and everything behind it to work is
actually an incredibly hard problem so
it makes sense to go after General
interfaces that uh okay they are not
perfect for any one given task but they
actually have the generality of just
with a prompt with English able to do
something across and so I think it makes
a lot of sense to go after a general uh
interface
um in the physical world and I think
it's a very difficult project I think
it's going to take time
um but I see no other no other company
that can execute on that Vision I think
it's going to be amazing like uh
basically physical labor like if you
think transportation is a large Market
try physical labor it's like insane
but it's not just physical labor to me
the thing that's also exciting is the
social robotics so the the relationship
we'll have on different levels with
those robots that's why I was really
excited to see Optimus like um people
have criticized me for the excitement
but I've I've worked with uh a lot of
research Labs that do humanoid legged
robots Boston Dynamics unitary a lot
there's a lot of companies that do
legged robots but that's the the
Elegance of the movement is a tiny tiny
part of the big picture so integrating
the two big exciting things to me about
Tesla doing humanoid or any legged
robots is
clearly integrating it into the data
engine so the the data engine aspect so
the actual intelligence for the
perception and the and the control and
the planning and all that kind of stuff
integrating into this huge the fleet
that you mentioned right
um and then speaking of Fleet the second
thing is the mass manufacturers Just
knowing
uh culturally
uh driving towards a simple robot that's
cheap to produce at scale yeah and doing
that well having experience to do that
well that changes everything that's why
that's a very different culture and
style than Boston Dynamics who by the
way does those robots are just the way
they move it's uh like it'll be a very
long time before Tesla could achieve the
smoothness of movement but that's not
what it's about it's it's about uh it's
about the entirety of the system like we
talked about the data engine and the
fleet and that's super exciting even the
initial sort of models uh but that too
was really surprising that in a few
months you can get a prototype yep and
the reason that happened very quickly is
as you alluded to there's a ton of copy
based from what's happening in the
autopilot yes a lot the amount of
expertise that like came out of the
Woodworks at Tesla for building the
human robot was incredible to see like
basically Elon said at one point we're
doing this and then
next day basically like all these CAD
models started to appear and people talk
about like the supply chain and
Manufacturing and uh people showed up
with like screwdrivers and everything
like the other day and started to like
put together the body and I was like
whoa like all these people exist at
Tesla and fundamentally building a car
is actually not that different from
building a robot the same and that is
true uh not just for uh the hardware
pieces and also let's not forget
Hardware not just for a demo but
um manufacturing of that Hardware at
scale is like a whole different thing
but for software as well basically this
robot currently thinks it's a car
uh it's gonna have a midlife crisis at
some point it thinks it's a car
um some of the earlier demos actually we
were talking about potentially doing
them outside in the parking lot because
that's where all of the computer vision
that was like working out of the box
instead of like an inside
um but all the operating system
everything just copy pastes uh computer
vision mostly copy paste I mean you have
to retrain the neural Nets but the
approach and everything in data engine
and offline trackers and the way we go
about the occupancy tracker and so on
everything copy paste you just need to
retrain the neural Lots uh and then the
planning control of course has to change
quite a bit but there's a ton of copy
paste from what's happening at Tesla and
so if you were to if you were to go with
goal of like okay let's build a million
human robots and you're not Tesla that's
that's a lot to ask if you're a Tesla
it's actually like
it's not it's not that crazy and then
the the follow-up question is and how
difficult just like we're driving how
difficult is the manipulation task uh
such that it can have an impact at scale
I think
depending on the context the really nice
thing about robotics is that um unless
you're doing manufacturing that kind of
stuff is there's more room for error
driving is so safety critical and so
that and also time critical like a robot
is allowed to move slower which is nice
yes I think it's going to take a long
time but the way you want to structure
the development is you need to say okay
it's going to take a long time how can I
set up the uh product development
roadmap so that I'm making Revenue along
the way I'm not setting myself up for a
zero one loss function where it doesn't
work until it works you don't want to be
in that position you want to make it
useful almost immediately and then you
want to slowly deploy it uh and uh at
scale and you want to set up your data
engine your improvement Loops the
Telemetry the evaluation the harness and
everything
um and you want to improve the product
over time incorrectly and you're making
Revenue along the way that's extremely
important because otherwise you cannot
build these these uh large undertakings
just like don't make sense economically
and also from the point of view I'm the
team working on it they need the
dopamine along the way they're not just
going to make a promise about this being
useful this is going to change the world
in 10 years when it works this is not
where you want to be you want to be in a
place like I think autopolis today where
it's offering increased safety and um
and uh convenience of driving today
people pay for it people like it people
purchase it and then you also have the
greater mission that you're working
towards
and you see that so the dopamine for the
team that that was a source of Happiness
yes you're deploying this people like it
people drive it people pay for it they
care about it there's all these YouTube
videos your grandma drives it she gives
you feedback people like it people
engage with it you engage with it huge
do uh people that drive Teslas like
recognize you and give you love like uh
like hey thanks for the for the this
nice feature that it's doing yeah I
think the tricky thing is like some
people really love you some people
unfortunately like you're working on
something that you think is extremely
valuable useful Etc some people do hate
you there's a lot of people who like
hate me and the team and whatever the
whole project and I think they're Tesla
drivers uh many cases they're not
actually yeah that's that's actually
makes me sad about humans or the current
the ways that humans interact I think
that's actually fixable I think humans
want to be good to each other I think
Twitter and social media is part of the
mechanism that actually somehow makes
the negativity more viral that it
doesn't deserve like disproportionately
uh add like a viral viral boost yeah
negativity but like I wish people would
just get excited about uh so suppress
some of the jealousy some of the ego and
just get excited for others and then
there's a Karma aspect to that you get
excited for others they'll get excited
for you same thing in Academia if you're
not careful there is a like a dynamical
system there if you if you think of in
silos and get jealous of somebody else
being successful that actually perhaps
counterintuitively uh leads the less
productivity of you as a community and
you individually I feel like if you keep
celebrating others that actually makes
you more successful yeah I think people
haven't in depending on the industry
haven't quite learned that yet yeah some
people are also very negative and very
vocal so they're very prominently
featured but actually there's a ton of
people who are cheerleaders but they're
silent cheerlead cheerleaders and uh
when you talk to people just in the
world they will all tell you it's
amazing it's great especially like
people who understand how difficult it
is to get this stuff working like people
who have built products and makers
entrepreneur entrepreneurs like make
making this work and changing something
is is incredibly hard those people are
more likely to cheerlead you well one of
the things that makes me sad is some
folks in the robotics Community uh don't
do the cheerleading and they should
there's uh because they know how
difficult it is well they actually
sometimes don't know how difficult it is
to create a product at scale right they
actually deploy in the real world a lot
of the
development of robots and AI system is
done on very specific small benchmarks
um and as opposed to real world
conditions yes
yeah I think it's really hard to work on
robotics in academic setting